mit dem hinduistischen Glauben bin ich
aufgewachsen und kann nicht wert wo im
Yoga vermittelt werden
aber Yoga ist zum Megatrend wurde und
hat pizarius gesagt statt Spiritualität
nur noch spaßevent
prostunde
Yoga es Milliarden geschafft hatte Weste
die indische Lehrer für Hund
[Musik]
also es geht uviel Angebot mit Yoga da
hat es zum Beispiel es wie Yoga es Yoga
mit Hund das nennt sich
also
und dann geht es natürlich an uns Stand
up Paddling Yoga das ist nicht neu
sondern auch schon gehört da gibt es nur
noch
andere
geht
nächster Halt
zu einem von den Angebot mache ich mich
auf den Weg
ich kann jetzt gerade zu meiner Angebot
wo ich mir recht schwierig vorstellen es
geht darum dass wir Yoga macht und dazu
renoviert trinkt das ist jetzt echt bis
wo ich jetzt ausprobieren aber ich kann
ja jetzt ist und
fragen Sie natürlich auch ganz jetzt da
ums Bier oder Gott
hallo
freut mich ich bin sofika
[Gelächter]
und du bist letzte Mal aber trinken
genau langsam Abend Schluck trinken
und beide knülle langsam zu der anderen
Seite spaßfaktoren
noch eineinhalb Stunden Hand blüht zwei
bis drei Flaschen Bier trinken und der
Bino Sport gemacht
ich muss mir wirklich Mühe geben zum
dadrin Joghurt
also ich sehe es nicht als dass man
quasi Yoga an sich nicht so bewahrt wie
es ursprüngliche entstanden ist sondern
man hat einfach ein bisschen kreiert und
es
lebe ich immer ein Wandel es ist immer
ein Wandel und es kommt immer wieder bis
Neues
kreiert wird so in der Stunde
dass Sie dass die meisten sich gar nicht
interessiert führt Philosophie hinter
Yoga und ja es wäre ehrlicher wenn man
jetzt nur sagen das ist jetzt
bierfitness oder das Workout mit Bier
oder so
vor drei und auch vom innere
Yogalehrerin
gehört als regelmäßiger zu machen
ich
binser finden was eigentlich
traditionelle Yoga ist und was man da
über den westliche Yoga Trend dankt
yoga hat zwar seine Ursprung in Indien
aber auch da in Bali ist Yoga
algergewärtig
ich treffe mich in U-Boot im Yoga
Hotspot von Bali mit Yogalehrer
spezialisiert
hallo
[Musik]
sie ist mein regular
[Applaus]
dass es beim Yoga machen um es
sportlicher
ich merke genau dass über Social Media
und in der vielen yoga-werbiges schrägst
Bild vor Yoga vermittelt wird schlanke
sportliche Frauen wo ich ihren gestalten
hat sie den Client das zu yogame gehört
aus perfekte ausgeführte Körperübungen
er unterrichtet hat der Yoga das ist die
traditionelle Art von Yoga was Schnuffel
meditieren und aussen aus also
Körperübungen hat
so ist
very easy but you feel the energy or is
from thed hellborn up to your Crown so
ist hart opening and hip openings
für mich ist es selbstverständlich dass
man in der yogast und meditiert und das
alle könnt Yoga machen auch wenn man
nicht beweglich und sportlich ist
[Musik]
natürlich wird auch da in balibur viele
Spiritualität
von Business wirklich ist möchte ich
unbedingt nur mit einem Guru reden
so jetzt bin ich gerade auch bei meiner
Schramm das ist das ist eigentlich wenig
Kloster für Hinduisten und ja eigentlich
sagen konnte
der look for
speech reality actuallyes
true Edition sen yoga practice that we
doing
of life
is thing final happiness
ich bin überrascht nach
buddhistische und christliche Statuen
[Musik]
eigentlich gar nicht spezifisch für
Hindus ist sondern eigentlich ist für
Spiritualität das heißt jede Person wo
egal wo wir Religion hat er ihnen
dass man sich auch Spiritualität widmen
es ist leider
Meditationszentrum aber jetzt zählt
Variante begegnet wo für mich so gar
nicht mit Spiritualität
freut mich
speziell für mich
es ist eigentlich ein normales Yoga
Stunde auf der Schweiz Kai ganz billige
mit 50 Franken ist die doppelte
[Musik]
noch eineinhalb Stunden wird sie will
dass man uns am Schluss noch mal über
die Yoga Stunde und Alpakas Gedanken
machen
herzlich sind sie schon aber Kürze
wirkliche
so eine alte Tradition vor ihnen wir und
jetzt bringt man sie daher bringt dann
no Alpaka Herren und so da wird jetzt
einfach kalt drauf verdienen obwohl
eigentlich traditionell Yoga nicht so
kommerziell wäre ja aber ich denke
traditionell Yoga das ist natürlich im
Westen
ich denke halt auch so wichtig dass jede
Person Möglichkeit hätte dies gespüren
vom Körper ihnen
Tradition so buchbüse im Westen bin ich
mir nicht sicher die Aussage
Kultur wo er Tradition hat wo zwischen
3000 und 5000 Jahre alt ist wenn dir
Traditionen Frage gestellt wird macht
mich das traurig dann fange ich als
verstorbene redet ich bin nicht gleich
neue Formen von Yoga aber Tradition
gehört schon dazu
konzentrieren ich kann jetzt nicht
wirklich eine abschalten und nur auf
mich
sind sie jetzt hinten aber ich habe das
Lied im Verlauf von der Stunden haben
sie sich recht gut kein entspannen
einfach weil stimmig oder will die
Alpaka so easy going sehen und und
entspannend sind das blüht halt einfach
downloaden
[Musik]
und dort bin ich ja auf der Suche
und ich kann in dein gefunden in der
Schule
[Musik]
Yoga gemacht haben das ist schon ganz
andere weiblich
so ernst Yoga macht und da so
passioniert ist
Yoga gehört da zum Stundenplan mit allem
was dazu gehört wie zum Beispiel
Atemübungen und Meditation
das sind Oberstufen und primagen
[Musik]
der schulgründer Guru
und wird mit der Zeremonie empfangen
[Musik]
und darum schrieb der seit über zwei
Jahre Bücher über die Philosophie
Ideen
macht sich über die Kommerzialisierung
[Musik]
schon lange nichts sehen vielleicht
danke
Lehrerin entspricht wo da im Westen
Business mit Yoga macht ist sie aber
benötigt
also mehr als
ich weiß noch
Yoga und du hast auch wenn man sich das
überhaupt
was für unglaublich entwickelt du
gemacht hast und da reden wir jetzt eben
nicht genau zu dem Mainstream hey wähle
Positionen
bitte Julie kann ich gelernt mit meiner
Gefühle
akzeptieren wo meine
ich weiterkomme
muss atmen
Betracht ziehen für die ist das
vielleicht da gar nicht unbedingt jetzt
ihre Lebensunterhalt sondern dir sagen
okay ich hoffe 80er Prozent und macht
dann 10%
das ist ein Grund warum sie der aktuelle
Yoga Trend so stört
fühlst du dich mitschuldig mit deiner
Schulen dass du zu dem Trend Beat hast
nein will mich hat
und jetzt geht es halt viele
mitfahren und für mich ist jetzt die
Frage fahre ich jetzt weiterhin oder
fahre ich jetzt ein anderer Weg ich
werde auf jeden Fall mit dem Trend
Mainstream Yoga Moments große
und ihre nicht Lust vergangen ich
persönlich hoffe dass sie bleibt
ich finde sehr cool dass Firmen kreativ
werden und auch burehöfe etwas Lustiges
arbeiten
und missbraucht worden für Marketing und
Yoga Anbieter Ihnen
sich wirklich zu interessieren für
Philosophie dahinter und ich als
hinduistin Hans Gefühl dass man Yoga zum
Teil verhunzt hat wo so eine Tradition
so eine lange Tradition hat und zu einer
Kultur gehört was denkst du ist es cool
dass es so viele
yoga-angebot gibt oder gab es alles okay